welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar impact of
cannabis prohibition on patients
veterans and small-business owners a
personal perspective presented by Joe
krumbine CEO of Willow Creek Springs
incorporated
my name is Xavier courtiers and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots leverage is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner at the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Joe Grimm bye I
will now turn things over to him
excellent well I thank everybody for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
here and I want to introduce myself my
name is Joe grandma and I am the CEO of
a company called Willow Creek Springs
and we're a small family business that
creates hemp-based products and we also
create CBD products and other cannabis
products and so part of this discussion
is my personal perspective about how
cannabis prohibition has impacted my
small business and also many others that
I've you know been involved with and
participate with I want to give sort of
a introduction of my qualification
I'm not a medical professional and I'm
not a legal professional but I work with
a lot of both of those and I have a lot
of personal experience I am in addition
to the CEO of Willow Creek Springs I'm
also the CEO of a civil-rights nonprofit
called the human solution international
and I'm going to be tying the work that
we do with defendants and prisoners into
this conversation as it is clearly part
of the impact of prohibition I have been
working with the cannabis plant for over
30 years growing it extracting making
compounds compounding I've been teaching
classes jeez I think since about 2000
classes on cultivation organic farming
herbal concentrates or herbal formulas
as well as compounding with infused
products standards dosing and that sort
of thing
I've been working with a number of
different schools and classes and that
sort of thing so I have a lot of
personal experience without some of the
fancy degrees and whatnot I am here to
talk about these things because I think
they have impacted so many people for so
long and I think that there's a lot of
misinformation about where we're where
we are where we're headed and why things
are prohibited and actually how they're
impacted how they impact people I think
that first I'm going to give kind of a
brief overview of cannabis prohibition
you know people think about cannabis
today and they think oh well it's legal
in so many places I'm a resident of
California and we've had laws that allow
for certain things for more
20 years and I talked to people
constantly and they you know say well
it's legal and they don't realize that
we're still in a system of prohibition
and I'm going to kind of explain that in
addition to these impacts so prior to
1930 cannabis was widely used as
medicine as a food fuel and fiber all
sorts of reasons it was used and not
going to get into a lot of details but
it was a it was it was a common plant it
was a plant that many people grew many
people used it was in the pharmacopoeia
up until about 1940 and in the 1930s a
couple of things happened alcohol
prohibition was just repealed and there
was this pretty mammoth machine to go
after the illegal alcohol businesses and
so to take its place
they developed the Federal Bureau of
Narcotics and Harry Anslinger was you
know the head of that well he came out
of the alcohol Bureau so it was kind of
a messed up situation because you know
they took all the funding for one thing
and they slid it over into another else
then they started looking at illegal
drugs in 1936 reefer madness was
produced and if you know anything about
information the public's perception
drives so many things social policies
and ultimately the laws are directed by
these public perceptions of things and
there began a campaign of fear of
racial bias of misinformation and hiding
information all of those things were
combined through different media outlets
so back in the 30s there weren't the
same kinds of media that we all have
here there wasn't webinars and there
weren't you know social media and online
anything there were newspapers and there
were movies and there was radio and you
know there were there was you know a lot
of word to mouth information so somebody
would get a hold of information they'd
pass it along information was a lot
slower to travel and information was
controlled by a very few number of
people so there were a few players that
were involved you got Harry Anslinger
and you've got William Randolph Hearst
he was a paper guy he controlled a lot
of the media he also had issues with the
hemp plant conflicting with his paper
that was produced by lumber mills you
know I would you also have Andrew Mellon
he was a wealthy individual that was
connected with Harry Anslinger and then
you have Lamont DuPont and if you're
familiar with the DuPont name he was
involved with the chemical industry made
I think it was rayon polyester that kind
of thing
made all sorts of petrochemical products
and if you know anything about the hemp
plant it is very much capable of
producing just about anything that crude
oil can the first internal combustion
engines were designed to run on a hemp
oil fuel anything that is made out of
oil the hemp oil can produce and again
that's a lot of technical stuff I'm not
going to put up a bunch of slides about
the wonders of him how
is a very wonderful plant food food fuel
fiber medicine it gives all of these
things so then they got the marihuana
Tax Act that all of a sudden for the
first time turned cannabis into a crime
and it restricted the use of it to just
a few people for medical and industrial
uses and it created a new class of crime
it created a new type of criminal and
again the literature that was put out
was directed at the fears and the racial
biases of people and you know it was
pretty effective here we are
many generations down the road and in
much of the reefer madness put up almost
in a satire his is taken as fact in
plenty of white papers that are that are
drawn up by cities and law-enforcement
agencies the same fears that they've
implanted so long ago that weren't based
on really any truths people still
believe today as fact
and you know that's part of the problem
of prohibition is it it's it's a stigma
that's been embedded ingrained in our
media and in a you know side of
information that comes at us you know
since the 30s nineteen forty four an
interesting thing happened there was a
LaGuardia report that came out and it
basically disproved all of these things
that were being implied by the reefer
madness and they said you know that's
this really isn't what's happening but
that report got suppressed and and Nixon
especially really buried it under the
rug they didn't want this information
the truth to get out and so through the
course of you know the next twenty
thirty forty years they
did a lot of things you know media-wise
to suppress this in 1950 through 1956
there were a couple of laws that were
passed and they imposed maybe for the
first time mandatory sentences for drug
crimes and this is where things really
started to go sideways as we're talking
about these impacts one of the main
impacts that covers across all of these
three categories is the criminal impact
think about this for a second
a plant that just grows and it grows
naturally wildly all over the planet
we have strains of cannabis that that
grow virtually on any con on every
continent set for maybe Antarctica and
it's tailored itself to the
environmental specialties of the of all
of these different areas and we decided
that the possession cultivation
transportation distribution manufacturer
of this plant is now crime we've
essentially criminalized a plant never
before it anything like that been done
it doesn't make sense to me today it
probably didn't make sense to a lot of
people as it was happening this was the
thing that was commonly used for so many
things and all of a sudden it was not
only a crime but a crime that was
punishable by mandatory minimums in 1970
this is when things really got sideways
so you know all the way up until 1970
there were all kinds of things that
could have happened and there were
people that had gotten locked up and
there were there were raids and all
kinds of things but once you got to 1970
Richard Nixon passed the Controlled
Substances Act and that's when things
really went south cannabis marijuana as
it was
as a negative term was put into Schedule
one category now of all the schedules
they start from five and they go up to
one I don't think there's a six but I
know that they go from the least harmful
to the most harmful as scheduled one is
a compound that is considered to have no
known medical use it is considered to be
highly addictive and it is considered to
be extremely harmful and if you look at
any study that's ever been done about
the cannabis plant you'll find out that
there isn't anything about this plant
that meets any of those categories and
it's one of the things that has always
troubled me because you know we have a
lot of people in our country that are
law-abiding citizens and they work hard
to be lawful and when you talk to them
about cannabis they will say something
like well I don't really have a problem
with it but it's illegal so I can't go
near it
I'm not gonna do anything that's illegal
I don't want to jeopardize my freedom I
don't want to risk it you know being
unlawful and there hasn't been this
giant outcry of well this is wrong now
if you think about some of the things
that our nation has done over the
history of our nation you know we've
done some pretty horrible things we've
oppressed whole groups of people we have
allowed for slavery we've allowed we've
not allowed women to own property to
vote all of these things that we've done
we've not allowed people a same-sex
persuasion to get married there's been
all these things that we've done in our
history and yet it was recognized over
time that these are not correct this
isn't right and changes have been made
and enough people got together enough
people were outraged and they made those
changes one by one we're gaining on it
not that we've fixed everything but I
can't help but wonder how this one got
left behind it's it's as egregious as
any of them in my opinion and maybe not
that the seminal simple act of creating
a crime out of something that shouldn't
be but the fact that people are locked
up people have lost their property
they've lost their lives they lost their
jobs they lost their children they lost
their businesses they've lost all of
these things simply because of this
plant a simple powerful effective
prohibition that goes across all of
these lines and yet there's not the
outrage that there's been with the
women's suffrage movement that there's
been with the civil rights movement and
in many ways I think cannabis
prohibition has affected at least as
many people and in maybe just as bad
you know if you think about the the
horrors of our civil rights problems
racism and slavery and all the horrors
that have happened through that some of
the same horrors have happened as a
result of the DEA and raids and you know
the things that have happened to people
plenty of people have been killed
they've been sentenced to long prison
terms life in prison can you imagine
today in 2019 there are people serving
life sentences for cannabis crimes today
right now at the same time that we have
people running stores that we have all
sorts of laws that are allowing certain
things and not others and yet
prohibition still is running strong
because we have people that are locked
for life today right now for cannabis
and nothing else I think just lays out
the problem specifically as it is that
as it reaches out to everybody now let's
start walking through some of these
groups of people I start with this small
business it's probably the easiest to
address now small businesses have been
affected by Prohibition specifically in
a lot of ways most small business owners
again as most people I think are in the
nation they tried to be lawful you know
if people don't start a small business
with the intent of breaking the law it's
it's kind of cross purpose if your goal
is to make a living to to grow a company
it would behoove you likely to follow
laws if you can write in California in
was in 1996 we passed Proposition 215
we're the first one or one of the first
ones to pass a medical law and in
essence it was a very broadly written
law on purpose that allowed for some
basic rights for people who qualified as
patients to grow possess consume produce
and distribute the cannabis plant and it
was written this way I've had a lot of
conversations with some of the authors
of this law because when a when there's
an ambiguity to Allah how the law is
supposed to work and if there's an
ambiguity to Allah and there's a
conflict with law enforcement and
there's a lack of clarity it's supposed
to err on the side of a defendant so if
you're accused of something and the law
doesn't clearly say you can't do it in a
in the way that you're being accused
you're supposed to have an allowance and
then they address it and correct the law
he'd be but in California as in so many
of the other states that have later on
ass laws that allowed for medical and
ultimately recreational cannabis use
what's happened is law enforcement the
courts have erred on the side of law
enforcement in the courts and for a good
long while a lot of people were getting
locked up even though they were in their
opinions following the law many times in
the opinions of legal experts that these
people had consulted and so you have a
whole generation twenty years in
California of people that had medical
gross medical collectives and all of the
all of the different facets of that
including manufacturing transportation
sales you know and all of the things
that have to do with it all of the
different facets of this and I want to
be mindful of all of these other crimes
that they have out there it's because
most of the time when you hear about a
legislative act that says oh we're
expunging all of these all of these
cannabis crimes and we're
decriminalizing this and we're doing
these things and people go out look
we're making so much progress generally
what happens and most of the laws that
allow for recreational and medical use
generally the things that they touch
most on is simple possession and granted
as this affects a huge swath of people
there are many many many people that
have been charged with criminal
possession most of the real problems
come from other charges possession with
intent to sell manufacture and
transportation and all of these things
and even conspiracies I don't think that
a lot of people realize
because again the media feeds us Oh
California we passed our rec law so
there are expunging all of these
felonies or all of these cannabis
charges but generally what they're
expunging and what they're removing are
simple possession cases I think it's
important to know that because rather
than stopping and saying okay we've
accomplished this we're done I think we
need to evaluate and say what is our
endgame what is the goal you know if
we're if we're a decommissioning
cannabis prohibition I think it needs to
be addressed and frankly most of the
time I don't think it is so you have
small businesses that have been turned
into criminals I live at one point in
19m sorry 2007 I had opened up a
cannabis collective medical collective
and ultimately I had three of them in 20
or again in 2009 I was arrested for the
first time in my life I was 40 what was
I 43 42 years old and I got arrested for
the first time in my life I was
following California law to the best of
my ability as far as I knew I should
have been an immune from this I knew
that there was federal law that still
applied and I knew that we took a risk
of violating federal law but we took
that risk a lot of times change
political and social change happens when
people are willing to take a risk people
are willing to challenge these laws
they're willing to stand up when the
state of California stood up to the
federal government said you know what
we're gonna go ahead and pass this even
though the Controlled Substances Act
stands and to this day it stands
unchanged as it was back in 1970 we took
that chance and it wasn't the federal
government that came in caused me
problems it was the state the state
arrested me and did
knives anything any of the medical
proofs that I had they just locked me up
and they charged me with crimes well
that's when I became aware that's when
that big light bulb turned on in 2009
sitting in a holding cell thinking to
myself I never even had a parking ticket
of speeding ticket I should say I've had
parking tickets
I've never been accused of a crime hell
I don't even have any enemies how is it
that I'm sitting here locked up with a
bunch of criminals and over the next
year I fought this case had to hire an
attorney continue to operate my
collective in fact just continued on as
I was pretty confident I was gonna beat
the case ultimately a year later and I
don't know I think about 20 trips to
court
I had my case dismissed and the judge
said I was found to be compliant with
all California law and my case was to be
dismissed and all my property was to be
returned
however the Riverside County Sheriff's
had forfeited my money that they seized
and sent it off to the federal
government they told me well you can go
ahead and get it from them as you can
imagine I didn't find that to be too
much of a good idea and took it as a
loss two weeks later I was raided and
this time they came in and to hit
everything same thing the state wasn't
the feds and they had determined that I
was a criminal they were gonna get me so
this time it was Long Beach it was LA
County well I spent the next six years
fighting that case and lost everything
I've ever had almost lost my home lost
my business lost friends family was
locked up over four times again with
criminal
you want to talk about an impact to a
small business it was a devastating
impact and it was devastating to all the
people around me it was devastating to
the people that supported me and
ultimately six years later I was
exonerated well you don't get anything
back you don't get your time back you
don't get the experience of being locked
up back you don't get the abuse back you
don't get any of those things back you
get to start all over again and I'm
thankful for that and I've taken this
opportunity to not only start all over
again but to thrive in the course of all
of these things that happened I started
a company called the human solution
international you see this little ribbon
here this is what we call a solidarity
ribbon and the human solution
International is an organization it's a
nonprofit that stands together and helps
people like me that have been charged
and we stand up in courts we get up as
expert witnesses we give personal
support we do we support prisoners we
support people that have lost their
their homes their families their jobs we
help out in a number of different ways
that's actually maybe a positive thing
that came out of prohibition when this
organization was formed so with regards
to small businesses today we now have a
huge conflict of laws we have the the
farm bill act that allows for the
production of hemp
we have CBD that is running all over the
place
big money's coming in the big Green Wave
coming in to all different places states
that have medical laws recreational laws
no laws at all in California we have CBD
that's being regulated differently then
the medical cannabis and the
recreational cannabis and it's it's it's
really convoluted the the regulations
that have come out of all of this I in
my opinion have caused as much or more
harm than good there are businesses that
are opening up believing that they're
following the law or not we have
recreational stores and medical stores
that have opened up and the handful of
them that have been able to comply with
the state laws have now turned on those
that haven't so now you have the very
people that used to be part of the
so-called cannabis movement that you
know we're all in the same boat a few
years ago and now a couple of them have
have moved forward and gotten certain
licensing and certain approvals and
they're going around now and they're
attacking those that don't because their
competition so it's you know again it's
turned brother against brother some of
the same stuff that's come out of you
know some of these other major problems
that the nation's had so as far as small
businesses go there's still a huge risk
there are merchants services that will
not process credit cards even for hemp
companies if you're a CBD company you
can't get a credit card processed the
banks won't take your money
you can't run a legitimate business even
though you might have a legitimate
license to have a legitimate business
there's no banking it's all FDIC insured
and the federal law says well this is
illegal so we have major problems
there's breakthroughs happening but they
haven't happened yet and when I was
going through my trial one of the things
that they accused me of was running an
all-cash business in their opinion that
was one of the indicators of an illegal
business the fact that I was in all-cash
business now that's not to say that
there aren't plenty of all cash
laundromats and restaurants and all
sorts of other small businesses but in
today's day and age
if you can't do banking it doesn't make
sense that you can be so-called a
legitimate business and not have that
legitimacy so now I want to talk about
veterans now I ran a collective again
for many years and I work with a lot of
veterans in my nonprofit and I've
interviewed many many veterans I'm not a
veteran I come from a family of veterans
that goes all the way back to the
Revolutionary War and I support the
people that think that that's important
and I think that it is an important
thing but regardless of that there are
people that have that have put their
cells in harm's way in the name of
serving our nation and they'll go out
and they'll be put into a combat
situation they'll have experienced
horrible things giving them mental
issues PTSD all sorts of problems and
not counting possibly being exposed to
chemicals and of course not even talking
about physiological injuries these
veterans come back home and in many
cases you know it goes sideways from
there with mental issues we have a
homeless veteran problem that is just
rampant but I want to talk more
specifically about just the veterans
access to cannabis and how cannabis
prohibition is has kept that from
happening I know a lot of veterans and
in fact that's the human solution
International has advocated for several
of them as they were fighting through
criminal cases that came from them
trying to treat themselves and I'll give
one case in particular a guy by the name
of Chris he was a marine served tours in
Afghanistan and the Middle East came
back he had injuries he had PTSD he had
all sorts of things the VA had put him
on a cocktail of I don't know it was
over 30 pharmaceutical drugs he had
almost lost his career over it because
these drugs put him into a stupor he
didn't
her things he would fall asleep he was
combative his marriage was falling apart
over it in young children he wasn't able
to take care of correctly everything was
wrong and it was these pharmaceutical
drugs that were the culprit he
discovered that cannabis might be
helpful started self-medicating within I
think it was six to nine months time I
have a several interviews with him but I
want to make sure I'd get the
information correct if I can he was off
of all of these medications and simply
using cannabis and one by one by the use
of cannabis he was able to stop taking
one and because he stopped taking one
the side effects from that so he could
stop taking another one and one by one
he eliminated all of these
pharmaceutical drugs and he was able to
function better than he was before but
what happens is when the VA finds out
that you're using cannabis they will not
allow you to have certain medications
they don't go after you or anything but
they'll say well you don't get to have
this pain medication that you might need
and I know there's a huge problem with
pain medications and opiates and that
sort of thing but sometimes they're
necessary and for periods of time
sometimes people have injuries or
conditions that require more than
cannabis from time to time but if you're
a veteran and they find out that you're
using cannabis you'll be cut off of a
number of different pharmaceutical drugs
pain relievers mostly and I have this
from personal experience now what has
happened in numerous cases is there's
been these memos and they you know the
the VA administrator will say well we're
looking into and we're looking at
allowing veterans to have cannabis use
but what always comes back is the
Controlled Substances Act
cannabis is Schedule one and what that
means is no you can't have it in a lot
of these cases going back to the small
business I've watched dispensary owners
in federal trials try to use as a
defense
you know the Cole memo the Ogden memo
these memos that Attorney General's had
issued over the years saying that well
we're not going to act if this that or
the other thing has happened and then
you get into court and you sitting with
a federal judge and what do they say
they say well that's not the law and in
this courtroom only the law applies and
there's only one law that applies and
that's the Controlled Substances Act and
what it says in essence is no you can't
have it so the federal government has
not changed its tune one iota when it
comes to cannabis when it comes to
possession cultivation transportation
distribution and the like no that's what
it says and even though they may not go
after everybody the way that they have
in the past they can and they could go
after any of these businesses it's
something that people need to be aware
of and I just don't think that that that
many are so as far as veterans goes
there is been a recent bill that's been
introduced and congressman Earl bloomin
our in the third District of Oregon
proposed a bill to the House of
Representatives that would allow VA
physicians to issue recommendations and
opinions to veterans who are residents
of states with state marijuana programs
according to the participation of
veterans and such state marijuana
programs hey that's a start
you know if the VA actually can get this
bill to go through and maybe they'll
recognize the need for this and this one
small thing maybe it'll open up the door
but today it's not and there are
thousands probably tens of thousands
maybe hundreds of thousands of vets that
are negatively impacted I worked with
the doctor clinical psychiatrist by the
name of dr. Fichtner and he had done a
study on PTSD in cannabis and again I
don't
enough time to get into the clinical
elements of all of this but he's
demonstrated you know in a limited
clinical study that cannabis can help
PTSD if we could just imagine that there
was a pharmaceutical drug that if it did
nothing else but helped you relax help
you sleep
helped you eat helps you generally feel
better and had no vet verified negative
side effects except for possibly an
occasional hunger dry mouth and a
general feeling of well-being if we had
a clinical pharmaceutical compound that
would do that the developer of that drug
would be rich beyond measure am i
describing anything you might be aware
of
oh yeah the cannabis plant and the
cannabis plant is guilty of just exactly
that all right now we're going to talk
about patients and you know time goes by
so fast when we start doing these things
so I'm trying to make sure I'm able to
touch on all the topics patients is a
giant word a patient is is anybody who
has an ailment an injury would be
needing medical attention in any way a
mental patient could be a patient
[Music]
somebody who has a disease could be a
patient somebody who has an injury could
be a patient and it goes on and on even
somebody who has an addiction to other
drugs and I want to jump right into that
because I think that's something that's
starting to be explored and I think it's
an important thing to address cannabis
prohibition part of its rhetoric is
simply that it's the gateway to hell it
is the precursor to other drug use it is
the thing that is the slippery slope the
stepping stone it's the it's the one
that you start you take a puff amaryl
and the next thing you know you're
slamming heroin they're finding out
today and we've been experiencing for 30
years that most I don't know about most
but a lot of people that have opiate
addictions didn't do anything wrong they
were following the law and they were
following the advice of their doctor
their medical professional who
prescribed them fda-approved
legal pharmaceutical drugs to help them
with pain to help them with whatever
that ailment was and they found
themselves addicted and in some cases
when I was running my collective I would
deal with clients I can't call them
patients but I I dealt with over 10,000
of them clients and as many of them
would come in to come me this and it was
a heartbreaking story they said you know
I had an operation and the doctor gave
me oxycontin or whatever the the opiate
was and it helped for a while but now
every month he gives me a month's supply
and two or three days before my supply
can be refilled I run out and every
month I have to go through withdrawals
and it's hell it's horrible I get sick
I just it's I want to die they tell me
that and you know at the time this was
before we had you know lab tested
concentrates but we had concentrates and
I would advise them well you know if you
were to try some of this and really you
know get yourself a decent dose um it
might be helpful and we discovered that
many times if not almost a hundred
percent of the time if somebody was to
actually do this right they would find
themselves weaning themselves off of
these opiates and they would come back
the next month and they say wow you know
what this month I had
pihl's left over and a couple of months
later they say you know what I'm cutting
my my my strength down and they would
one by one I mean it didn't happen every
time but it happened plenty of times one
by one they would say you know what I'm
free I'm free of this addiction and it
was cannabis that did it and I can't I
had an epiphany when that happened you
know the first time the second time the
third time I met it said wow you know
it's the Gateway out of hell and maybe
there's something we could do about it
and I'm working with a number of
physicians right now on you know
programs to help people get off of
addiction alcohol tobacco opiates and
we're having some some good effect
imagine if we didn't have cannabis
prohibition and we could use these
medicines early on in as an adjunct
therapy maybe give them the heavier dose
opiates as they you know are in the
throes of a recovery of a major injury
and use the cannabis therapy to get him
off quick imagine that the years of life
and the lack of organ damage and all the
problems that have come from these these
pharmaceutical drugs it's just something
to think about
psych meds how many people today are on
psych meds you know they're there's all
kinds of negative side effects that can
happen if you look at most document
prescriptions you'll see you know
warning on may cause suicidal thoughts
this thing that's supposed to help you
make fit make you feel better might make
you want to kill yourself we talked
about FDA approval we talked about all
of these things as though they're the
only thing that matter and yet this is
the thing that doesn't get addressed it
doesn't get it dressed often enough it
gets addressed occasionally but not not
often enough and not to the right people
there has not been one proven case of
anybody died from cannabis
one why isn't that being driven home
don't know the answer to that but I do
know that cannabis prohibition is still
running rampant and it's making it so
that people that otherwise would have
access to this don't it has created an
environment where people have had to
flee their homes in states where there
is not any access whatsoever they've had
to make choices between being legal and
lawful and doing the right thing taking
care of their children that have
seizures taking care of their selves or
their loved ones that have cancer can
you imagine an impact of prohibition
that would be more powerful than having
to choose do I break the law and risk
getting thrown in jail losing my home
losing everything losing my children or
do I take a chance and take a chance of
of a treatment that might save me cancer
for an example I don't know just a thing
that I don't have nearly enough time to
discuss but we have documented cases
hundreds thousands of them of people
treating themselves with cannabis oil
and watching tumors shrink and go into
remission and doing nothing else now I
can't claim anything but I've watched it
over and over again and every one of
those people have taken a chance can you
imagine the angst that these people go
through when they make a choice like
that do you know the harm that stress
can cause imagine what it might be like
if we ended cannabis prohibition and
somebody could just go and get the soil
and get these treatments I've watched
people get off of psych meds I've
watched people shrink tumors I
watch people do all of these things but
they were taking a chance they had to
risk a criminal action and I have
watched people that took that chance and
got caught you want to know an impact a
negative impact of cannabis prohibition
you watch a sick person I stop there in
a trial
I don't many many trials but one in
particular a woman who had cancer and
had AIDS and had used cannabis to treat
herself they had a little garden wasn't
a huge garden and the state came in and
raided them took all of their medicine
and in some cases that is the biggest
impact of them all there's a man by the
name of Peter McWilliams early on in the
in the medical law of California and he
died because he didn't get his medicine
and a prolific writer and public speaker
an amazing guy but he didn't get his
medicine because of prohibition and now
he's not with this anymore
there are so many people I know a woman
named Dolores from Missouri her
husband's not with us anymore
she got raided from a small small grow
that they had and that's been didn't get
the medicine he needed and while he was
in custody or going through their case
he passed away later on she was an RN
later on she had to go through losing
her license and she had to go through a
hearing she had to go through a hearing
for moral turpitude can you imagine
being charged with a moral crime with a
with the ethics violation because you
had grown a plant that helped you and
your husband and and maybe some sick
people that you knew ultimately my nan
profit was able to intervene and and and
we had a pretty substantial campaign and
she ended up getting her license back
and she's practicing today but if you
want to talk about negative impact of
cannabis prohibition so I've only got a
couple of minutes left and I want to get
into maybe the most important part what
can we do about this we have passed law
after law after law and people believe
that this work is done we're positioning
ourselves for Big Pharma to take control
of these compounds and the people are
not going to be able to have it people
keep talking about scheduling it to two
or three or four or five a schedule five
substance still needs to be prescribed
you're not going to be able to access
this plan unless we decriminalize it
there are laws in the book I mean there
are bills going through both sides of
Congress right now that could ultimately
decriminalize this plant but they died
in committee every session we could get
active we could start talking about this
at the end of the day if Big Pharma
controls this it's not going to change
one bit the black market is going to
continue and prohibition will still
exist I realize I'm running out of time
I am very grateful for the opportunity
to to communicate with everybody I want
you to be mindful that there are still
people in prison today there are still
people going through trials today there
are people being raided today there are
sick people that are not able to get
medicine and imagine this okay you
passed a law you got a recreational law
you can go to a store you need oil
because you have cancer and guess what
you can't afford it and your insurance
is not going to cover it I don't know
you know it's not over folks we can make
a difference I encourage you to
participate if you want to get involved
can contact the human solution
international I'm here to answer any
questions hopefully we'll get lots of
questions that come out of this and
hopefully we can make the change and
leave a world for our kids or a
prohibition is over I thank you very
much I think my time is up and I think
that's it
thank you Joe for sharing your
perspective I would also like to thank
glaber's for making today's educational
webcast possible and as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye